you
[Music]
okay so to start off our our last
session we have an Eric Waukesha from
OSU who's going to talk us about talk to
us about variational programming please
take it away
I'm I'm up here from Oregon State I'm
our one representative here so I wanted
to briefly show our group so this is
just the programming languages group
we're pretty small just two faculty
members and some grad students a couple
grad students were out sick on this day
unfortunately but and then we've got
about four software engineering faculty
members as well so so yeah I'm gonna be
talking about variational programming
and this work was originally motivated
by a problem that comes up in the
context of highly configurable software
systems so the idea here is that you
have a code base and this represents not
just one program but lots of different
programs so for example it's a software
product line or it's an open source
program that has lots of configuration
options and features that can be turned
on or off and so the usual usual
workflow for sort of making a running
program out of out of this codebase is
the first thing that you do is you
configure it so you pick the features
that you want and you generate a program
that can actually be compiled and then
maybe you do some some program analysis
on that make sure that it works we run
the test suite on it and then if it
works you can go ahead and deploy it and
so the problem with this workflow
especially in the context of open source
software is that often the persons that
generating and evaluating this program
that wants to deploy it is not the same
person that wrote the code in the first
place right so the person that wrote the
code they sort of understand all of the
the configurations the person that
generates a configuration it's very
likely that you can generate a
configuration that's never been
generated before because these things
have hundreds or even thousands of
configuration options they don't know
what to do with the error that they get
back they don't even maybe maintain this
code at all so this this process finds
the errors too late and but the person
that writes the code they can't
anticipate all the configurations that
somebody might want to generate there's
just way too many of them so so the
solution to this problem is something
that we call a variational analysis so
what we do is we instead evaluate the
the configurable
base directly and we call this a
variational analysis and what this gives
us is it gives us a variational result
and the key thing here is that this
variational result conceptually
represents the result for all of the
configurations that can be generated
from this program so if we apply a
configuration to the original program
and run the standard program analysis we
get the same thing as if we apply that
same configuration to the variational
result and so now we can do things like
evaluate all of our configurations in
advance so the person that generates the
the configuration that they want to
deploy doesn't encounter an error so
we've done lots of work on developing
languages theory data structures and
algorithms to do this sort of thing
correctly and efficiently and
collectively we call this variational
programming so I want to give a so sorry
so the first example of this that we did
so this is when I was a grad student is
variational typing so this is just a
sort of concrete instance of this last
slide here so in this context so
normally you have lambda calculus you
run the hindley-milner algorithm you get
a type you infer type for that program
so here we have a variational lambda
calculus and we can run variational
typing on that and get back a
variational type and the types that are
represented here correspond to all of
the types of each of the configurations
okay and in order to implement this
variational typing box here we need
variational programming so I'm going to
give an idea of what variational
programming is by an example this is
sort of a fancy name for a simple idea
so the fundamental concept in
variational programming is something
called a choice so here's an expression
with a choice in it a choice has a
dimension so in this case a and two
alternatives so we can select the left
or the right branch from a dimension and
we get the corresponding alternative so
if we were to evaluate this program with
the choice in it we'd get back a
variational result with a choice in the
corresponding dimension if we have
multiple choices in the same dimension
they're going to be synchronized so if
we evaluate this
we'll get 12 and 23 because if we choose
the left branch for me we get the left
branch of both
choices in a if we have choices in
different dimensions they're independent
so if we evaluate this program we're
going to get four different alternatives
corresponding to all the four different
ways that we can configure this
expression the alternatives of the
choice can have different types as well
so here's an example of a choice where
one alternative is a boolean and one
alternative is an integer and so we have
choices also at the type level here so
here a choice in the expression induces
a type with a choice in the same
dimension and so here's another another
example of an expression with two
differently typed alternatives and what
we can see here is that when we have
sort of a structured value in this case
a type we can push the choices into the
type so this type is exactly equivalent
to two this choice type here which more
directly corresponds to the type of this
expression so success or us type into
int even has type int a bool and so we
can factor this comment in argument out
okay so of course we can evaluate so
here's another example of applying of
applying an example sorry applying two
different functions that have two
different types to two different values
so the not function expects a boolean
returns a bool even expects an int and
returns a bool and what we see here is
that in both cases the result is false
right so we have two completely
different expressions not applied to
true and even applied to three but both
of them return false and so we return
here is just the value false so we no
longer have a choice this is equivalent
to this expression but we can sort of
forget about the fact that we had a
variation there because we we don't need
it going forward and so this is going to
be key to sort of computing efficiently
with these things and here's just a more
complicated example here this represents
four different expression successor
applied to to success or applied to four
and even applied to both two and four I
mean what we can see here is we get a
more complicated variational value where
where one of the where we've had some
sort of folding inside of a or so it's
some sort of about collapsing on inside
of a choice okay so so that's sort of
just preserving variation across com
mutations we can also reflect on the
variation that's in a computation so
here's an example of a function V sound
I'm not showing how this is implemented
but basically what this is going to do
is this is going to look at the
alternatives that are in the result and
sum them all up so it's going to sum up
all of the results here so this is going
to sound 12 13 22 and 23 which gives us
70 we don't have any variation in there
anymore because we've accumulated all of
these alternatives and we can also do
things like pick out a particular
variation here so here again we've got
the same expression and what we want to
know is we want to know what's the
maximum value in there and so we get
back the value 23 but oftentimes we also
want to know which configuration that
value came from and so we can we can
return that in the results as well okay
so that's that's variational programming
by example so the first challenge that
comes in here is that the space of
potential variance grows exponentially
in the number of dimensions that you
have so in in the worst case this is
obviously very bad so the trick to sort
of doing this is first of all to share
as much as possible so we don't want to
introduce choices until we absolutely
have to so that's what I mean by
splitting late and anytime we have two
alternatives that converge to the same
value we want to eliminate choices as
soon as we can when we have structured
data we also need to use clever data
structures I'll talk about that a little
bit more here in just a second but
probably the most important thing to do
is just pick the right domains so some
domains don't have enough sharing in
them for this for this to really work so
if you're doing numerical simulations or
something like that and this probably
isn't going to work
the other challenge is that variation is
sort of like sand so sand gets in
everything and variation also gets into
everything so when you're writing one of
these variational analyses the sand just
gets in or sorry the same the variation
just gets into every incremental data
structure and every incremental value
that you're working with so in
particular when you have structured data
the idea of choices just sort of starts
to break down so here's a really simple
example where we have a choice between
two lists so we have one two three and
one two
four or five I mean so we can see
there's some redundancy here so ideally
we could factor this out in some way
so one idea is that we sort of push the
choices into the list but then it's sort
of not really clear what to do here
because we we have an element in one
variant and not in another and so we
need some we need some specialized
representation for variational lists and
it turns out we sort of need lots of
specialized variational data structures
for for different kinds of structured
data and originally I sort of had this
vision that this would all be very
systematic and the variational data
structures that work best so far seem to
just be ones that we should develop ad
hoc for each particular domain so this
is something that really still needs
more more work the other problem is what
to do about side effects so when we have
choices in programs and side effects if
you say print out something inside of a
choice we can't sort of make two copies
of the world one where we printed out
the value and one where we didn't so
what do we do there and this is
something one of my grad students is
working on
okay so returning to variational typing
real quick this is sort of an ideal
domain for this problem so there's lots
of sharing lots of configurations of a
program end up having the same type so
that's great it turns out that for
realistic programs the scale is roughly
linearly with the size of the program so
we don't encounter this this explosion
of the of the variation space and this
even scales to programs as big as the
Linux kernel so christian Kestner at CMU
implemented a tool called type chef that
is basically the same ideas here and he
can type check the all the
configurations of the Linux kernel it
takes about a day but but it's doable
okay so variational typing is sort of
the ideal scenario we've done this also
for for several other us and other
people have done this for several other
analyses of software product lines but
it seems like this idea of choices
should be more general than not so for a
while we sort of felt like we had this
cool hammer and we were looking for
nails to to to hit with it we just
always sort of an awkward position to be
and that's not really the right way to
do research right but but yeah this is
what we did I guess
so so so we started thinking about what
are the properties that make a good nail
so it needs to be something that has
lots of variation in it right because
this is where this variational
programming idea really pays off but it
also needs to have lots of sharing
between the different variants so types
good numerical simulations bad okay so
it's sort of the key insight was that
the the original problem or the original
program that we're working with doesn't
necessarily need to have the variation
instead we can use the idea of variation
to explore hypothetical situations so so
at points we're sort of in a traditional
say program analysis we have to make a
decision to commit to one path or the
other we can instead just introduce a
choice and explore both paths okay so
let's look at an example of that okay so
Michael talked about fault localization
so the problem of error location in the
context of type checking is is related
to this so the idea here is that when
you run your type checker sometimes you
get a type error and locating where the
actual conceptual error that caused that
type error is a hard problem that's been
around since the 80s and I think the
research probably looks very similar to
fault localization where there's sort of
all these new approaches to this and
everyone's better than the previous one
according to the papers including ours
but all right so here's an example of a
program so there's no variation in this
program this is just a plain high school
program that exhibits this problem okay
so here we've got first at the top here
we've got a definition of the fold
function so this is a left fold
we've got flip which flips the order of
its arguments we've got reverse
implemented in terms of fold and flip
and then finally we have a function
palindrome that checks to see if a list
is a palindrome by checking to see
whether the original list is equal to
the reverse of the list
does anybody see the bug in this program
okay so so the bug in this program well
let's let's see what GFC has to say
about it so here's what GHz says so GHz
gives us this you know it's sort of sort
of complicated but ultimately it gives
us a location for the air so it says the
problem is in Reverse X's equals equals
X's okay that looks fine to me so it
turns out that's not really where the
conceptual source of the error so the
conceptual source of the error is that
our base case of fold L is wrong so the
very first line of fold L is incorrect
that should just be we should just
return the base case there are not a
list containing the base case so there's
an error in the base case of fold but
fold without any type annotations
actually type checks the use of fold
later in the reverse function also type
checks we don't actually detect the
error until until sort of this two uses
later in the palindrome function when
GHC finally detects the error okay so
this is a problem and we can see it
exhibited here in GHC okay
so there's been lots of work on how to
improve error location so so the
solution so this is this is actually
worked by Sen Chen and Martin Ehrlich so
two of my collaborators but this is a
really cool application I think of
variational programming so basically the
problem is that locating the cause of a
type errors is hard and the reason is
that type inference commits too early
so here when fold type checks correctly
it commits to the type that it infers
for fold and but but the problem is that
a successfully inferred type could still
be wrong right so just because type
inference succeeded doesn't necessarily
mean the type that was inferred is the
correct one so the solution is that when
we infer a correct type we still sort of
keep open the possibility that that type
could be wrong so so we we assume that
the type either could be correct or
could still be wrong so the way
counterfactual typing works is that we
basically perform variational type
inference
so error tolerant here means that if one
particular branch
type inference fails we don't fail the
whole process this is important because
we're dealing with a program with type
errors in it
but for every sub expression so every
single sub expression in our in our
program when we infer type T for the sub
expression e we instead introduce a
choice type here so we instead say e is
a choice in some dimension D that's
either the type that we inferred or it's
a fresh type variable here so the
dimension is fresh and the type
variables fresh and we do this
everywhere and when we're done we get
this variational result with lots of
dimensions in it
and we're going to search that
variational type that we get back for a
value that's not an error type and that
has as few right selections as possible
right so right selections correspond to
places where the inferred type was wrong
right so we want a type where we have to
this basically is a measure of how many
changes we have to make in order to fix
our program so it's basically saying
what was written here was wrong and so
we're sort of using this type variable
to capture that we might have put
anything else in there anything with it
with a different type and so we search
our variational type for something where
we have to make as few right choices as
possible and it turns out that this this
this gives us the location where we have
to make the smallest number of changes
to to find the error or to fix the error
as possible and then we apply some other
heuristics that help us be better than
everybody else before us ok so that's
one problem so the oh shoot I'm slightly
over so ah so we also apply this to
gradual typing it's really cool but I
took way too long explaining the other
thing so so let me just say real quick
so gradual gradual typing is all about
mixing static and dynamic types but a
big problem with them is migrating
between gradually typed programs so the
the problems that can occur are that
when you're adding typed annotations you
can get into a place where you sort of
can't add anymore type annotations but
you're not in the most statically typed
program there's also potential for huge
performance degradation so there's
papers written
about how gradual typing is broken
fundamentally because of this
performance degradation problem so
basically the idea is that we do the
same trick that we did in counterfactual
typing and we can basically introduce
choice types for every parameter and
explore the whole space of potential
gradual type migrations and find ones
that satisfy different criteria that we
want and so yeah this this paper was at
Popple this year I put a little cross
fingers next to I CFP our reviews were
good so hopefully in a week we find out
that we have a nice you have a paper on
it too ok so sorry I went over the
variational programming makes variation
explicit and we can use this to explore
hypothetical scenarios Thanks
[Applause]
okay are there any questions for Eric
about variational programming it's late
in the afternoon don't be shy one thing
I was curious about there's like there
are a lot of dues admission like
simulations is a bad option mm-hmm but
actually there's a lot of simulation
packages that have a lot of variations
for accuracy so like C gal is the one
that sticks out of my mind where they
have like 80 different flavors depending
on like how much you're going to spend
on floating-point I wonder so the but I
guess the the reason I assume numerical
simulations will be bad is because we
never have this situation where
alternatives converge to the same value
so when typing this happens a lot
because different configurations have
the same type and so we can forget about
the choices basically but yeah I don't
know I mean I mean we can talk about
this more maybe in this case where it's
different amounts of precision maybe
this does occur well actually the
problem is they don't converge back so
okay you're totally right yeah that's
why there's bi yeah all right any other
questions for Rick okay so up next oh
I'm so sorry Doug it's a good question
but so you mentioned that you could that
I you've had trouble sort of finding
anything like general with variational
data is there something about
like derivatives some types that would
help here like you it seems like your
variational data structures are like
you're you're modifying something in
some way and you want to record those
modifications so yeah
so I mean I thought about this like it
like using zippers or something like
this yeah so I still think there's
potential for this here but the problem
is that yeah so I mean the problem is
just that you can get better performance
than sort of introducing choices in in a
derivative of a datatype by just doing
something special so I mean yeah this is
hard to hard to say without examples but
I'm yeah we can talk about this offline
maybe awesome ok
ok so up next Brad's going to tell us
what's been going on with the chapel
language at Cray great thanks so I'm
Brad Chamberlain I'm a principal
engineer at Cray here in Seattle and I'm
the technical lead for the chapel
project which I'll be talking a bit
about today this is the official talk
from my title for my talk but I have
this bad habit of making up dumb titles
the night before I give talks so this
will make more sense as we go along if
you not familiar with chapel it's a
productive parallel programming language
that we're developing at Cray it's
portable and scalable which means it can
run on your laptop your cluster the
cloud on a Cray and it's open-source and
collaborative which means we're
developing it a github under the Apache
License the two main goals of Chappel
are to support general parallel
programming which you can think of as if
you've got a parallel algorithm in your
mind and some parallel hardware you'd
like to run it on Chappel should be able
to do that and the second goal is to
make parallel programming its scale far
more productive than it is today now
that term productive means different
things to different people
one way that I'll explain it is to
compare two other languages so one
language that's is easy to read and
write code into say a Python but yet is
as fast as a Fortran as scalable as MPI
which is how most people do large-scale
HPC programming today as portable as C
as flexible as C++ and as fun as your
favorite programming language so that
you get excited about using chappell so
one way that will kind of visualize you
know how we're doing here is by looking
at the computer language benchmarks game
in here I've taken the languages that
are involved in the game and I've
plotted two points for each one which
were the geometric means of their
fastest programs and their smallest
programs in terms of code size so the
closer they are to the bottom of the
slide the faster the language is the
closed
to the left the smaller the codes are in
the language and so as you'd expect the
scripting languages are further off to
the left here but much slower and then
if we zoom in on who's down there at the
right we see C C++ Fortran um rest but
of course their codes are also much
bigger now I've left chapel off here but
if we add the chapel entries to this
then we're sort of off here down to the
left what you can think of as being
productive because you're sort of fast
and small and if i zoom back out we're
sort of again uniquely down to the left
compared to where most other languages
fit nowadays now of course we all know
that language language succinctness
isn't necessarily the best metric of
productivity so the the website also
lets you go in and look at the programs
and for the chapel you can see things
like these high-level Kovach in and co
for all constructs which create tasks
whereas in the CN tree you can see
things like schedu and things that
hopefully most of you have never had to
deal with in your life okay so that's a
little bit about chapel when I was
approaching this talk I sort of said
well I could talk about a number of
things and my reviewers each one of me
to talk about something different which
I should have anticipated but one of the
quotes that stuck out for me was this
one which said chapels been around for
quite a while and it still seems like a
niche language which one of the things
that sort of hurts your heart here but
is arguably true and I think a lot of
people share this perspective so I
wanted to dive into this a little bit
and say I'm first of all are we in each
language and you know one way in which
you could view us as being niche is that
chapel is originally designed for HPC
and HPC is arguably a niche field within
computer science but that said if we
step back and look at Chapel Chapel
cares about performance and I think a
lot of people even outside of HPC care
about performance we've heard a lot of
about that today
um chapel cares about program ability
and I think the rise of things like
Python show that people care about that
chapel cares about parallelism and
multi-core means that we're all arguably
able to be parallel programmers nowadays
and it also cares about scalability or
distributed memory and with the rise of
cloud computing you can see that that
has become bigger and bigger over time
so you know I would argue the chapel
while developed originally for HPC
actually has a lot of applicability
outside of HPC as well and as language
matures we're hearing that from a lot of
non HPC programmer
as well another way you could consider a
snitch is that we really have a very
modest sized user community like it's
not a sort of a line it's not a Python
right we'd love to be as large and
successful community as Python is but
something you have to know is that
historically if you came to me and said
should i program my next production half
inch Apple historically my answers been
no probably not yet and that gets me to
the quiche part of the talk so I think a
lot of people a community who've maybe
heard about Chapel over its lifetime say
like well why aren't more people using
this delectable language and in their
mind they've sort of got this picture of
this lovely quiche that we've been
making but the reality is that over the
large fraction of the the program's
history we've been putting this quiche
together and you know you probably don't
want to eat it just yet but you know
read the recipe sample the ingredients
see if you think we're on a path that's
going to be attractive to you and I'd
say where we are today is kind of here
where you know it's perhaps almost fully
baked and maybe it's time to take a look
at it again if it's something that's of
interest to you so going to the other
part of that reviewer comment that has
been around for quite a while so that's
accurate as well Chappell came out of
the DARPA HPC s program that ran from
2003 to 2012 at that time we were very
much a research focus a small team of
six to seven people and I think we
accomplished some great research
objectives in the parallel language area
but at the end of the day we had a
research prototype we didn't have
something that people can really use so
what we've been doing since then is what
we call the five-year push this has been
a five year effort to basically move
Chappel from research more to product
and we doubled the size of the team as
part of that and we focused in these
three main areas performance and
scalability on building up the ecosystem
around chapel and fixing things in the
base language that weren't directly
related to perils mer or scalability and
this third one is probably of most
interest to this crowd but doesn't fit
at all in a ten minute talk so I'm going
to touch slightly on the first two and
I'm going to compare kind of then where
were we at the end of HPC s in the start
of this push versus now where are we
today and I'll start with the ecosystem
then versus now so when we came out of
HPC s in terms of documentation we had a
PDF language specification we had a
quick reference sheet we had a number of
text-based readme files and we had
some premier examples that taught you
the language through comments and code
and now we're at a point where we have
over 200 modern hyperlinked web-based
documentation pages and when you surf to
Chapel it feels more like a real
language and less like somebody's
experiment in terms of libraries at the
end of each pcs we had about 25 library
modules some of them were documented in
source code
some of them were not really documented
at all we're now at a point where we
have about sixty library modules all of
them are documented on the web and many
of these have been user contributed and
then in terms of tools at the end of H
pcs we add highlighting modes for Emacs
and vim we had chapel dock or at least a
rough draft which was a documentation
tool and now we have those as well as
Mason package manager' a seated chapel
aid for interoperability on chapel tags
which allows you to search your source
code bash tab completion and then this
performance visualizer over on the side
here chapel vis so a lot of great
improvements to the ecosystem
performance is another thing that's
traditionally been a problem for Chapel
if you ask most people in HPC about
chapel they say oh it's that really
pretty language that performs really
terribly and in HPC of course that's
kind of a killer so over the last five
years we've done a lot with performance
this is a bit of a laundry list but in
short we've done a lot of locality
oriented things particularly within
multi socket nodes and a lot of
communication reduction across nodes and
so if I went back to where were we then
this is a stream performance benchmark
and higher is better and I'm adding
nodes across the axis at the bottom here
and so you can see that as we added
knows the performance got better as
you'd expect um but if you compare that
to where we are today we've you know we
were about third of the performance
we're getting today and of course now
you should be suspicious to say well how
do we know that you're good today well
if we compared to the reference version
in green here you can see that we're
tracking it pretty closely with just a
little bit of hit due to our elegance
looking at a second example this is a
stencil computation at that end of HPC s
time period again it's getting faster as
we add nodes but if we add today's onto
there basically the red line goes all
the way down to the axis we just were
terrible in terms of raw performance
then and again if I add me in the
reference you can see that we're
tracking it very closely today so you
can do it look at this across a number
of HPC computations
these handle things like
just local loops embarrassing Apparel's
l'm buck of exchange stencils global
random updates and in all these cases
we're doing quite well compared to the
reference version I'll go into one more
in a bit more detail the global random
updates here this is the code for the
MPI version of this benchmark as you can
see it's almost as elegant as chapel at
the top there is a comment and this
comment tells you what this code does
basically it's just doing random updates
to a globally distributed table and this
is the chapel loop for that same kernel
and as you can see the actual
computation is about the size of the of
the MPI computation this is another case
where we're not only scaling
competitively with the reference version
but in fact outperforming it okay so
what's next for us next week we've got
our annual workshop it'll be up in
Vancouver so it's local ish this year on
if you've got friends or colleagues or
students who are interested in parallel
computing and languages I'll send them
up it's generally bennett considered a
high-energy workshop and as we look
forward we're kicking off a new
three-year effort where we're gonna be
continued to work on performance and
scalability i'm targeting lib fabric
targeting GPUs targeting the cloud and
working on AI this is our team at Cray
again they're about 13 of us working on
a full-time at any given time we also
have an intern program and we'd love to
have your students apply to that it's an
open source effort so we have community
partners as well you notice there's a
sort of disturbing lack of civic
northwest education and industry on here
and we'd love to correct that if anyone
would like to collaborate in this area
and I think just to leave you here I
will just skip ahead to my summary slide
so we've made huge progress over the
past five years we think Chappell is
ready for production but I put an
asterisk there because different people
have different ideas of what production
means and again we're open to
collaborations last thing I'll mention
is that we have some chapel swag in the
form of screen or glasses wipes up here
on the chair if you need one and I've
got five minutes for questions
[Applause]
[Music]
if I have it I can start all right
question so you showed how versus at the
end of sort of the the DARPA program hph
pcs right yeah at the end of HP pcs you
know compared to that your performance
is way way better right did is the code
the same are you running the same
program and getting that much better
performance or as they are the
implementations updated as well yeah no
so in this case what we did was we took
today's code and we actually took that
old release and ran it on today's
Hardware so as his apples to apples as
possible and in some cases we had to
take the code and maybe sometimes we
relied on a newer feature we had to
rewrite that using a slightly older
feature in order to get it to run on the
old version but by-and-large is sort of
it's the more or less the same user code
that you would write so yeah so it's
it's meant to be as fair of a comparison
as possible and it just speaks to how
poor we were in that time frame in terms
of performance another thing I'm curious
about so in this distributed setting I
mean if you have sort of some kind of
like work-stealing or something you know
depending on how the schedule ends up
you might do floating-point operations
in a different order yeah do you ever
worry about that for like the like even
just for reproducibility I mean yeah I
mean so right so certainly
reproducibility is a concern among some
of christ' customers and they sort of
want things just so we don't actually do
much in the way of work stealing at
least across nodes but still as a
parallel language you tend to have
operations happening in different orders
and things like that so we have ways of
kind of locking down order but of course
at the expense of parallelism and
therefore maybe performance for people
who do need that reproduce a
reproducibility but in general you can
run to the sorts of errors like we saw
in the floating-point talk earlier with
you know if you do things the wrong
order like you may get wildly different
results now it sort of goes along with
parallel computing and unfortunately the
world we're used to living in for the
most part so do you guys have a sort of
like regression test to ensure that your
so I guess you have some flag it's like
make this reproducible right I mean it
seems like that's the whole way down
right there's like both on the network
there's a cross scores and then even
within the core right if you want to
exploit sim D a lot of times you'll do
some unrolling and reassociation so like
I mean there's so many levels for
reproducibility for these kinds of large
jobs how do you make sure that you've
actually found all of them that seems
really tough yeah I don't think
have a really good solution there to be
perfectly honest the interesting
research challenge if somebody in the
region is looking to collaborate maybe
you could think of
we would love librarians around that
room and I think you guys have the chops
for it as well I see two hands here
Charlie so you said your cloud ready how
easy is it to start up say other
Chappell nodes on someone's cloud so
today the main cloud that we've had the
most experience with is AWS and there's
sort of a readme that tells you how to
grab the thing and set up your machine
image just so and build it we've talked
about building a sort of pre deployed
machine image so you can just grab it
without having to do the build and
everything but we've never quite crossed
that path we're interesting and doing
the same for the other major cloud
providers so if any of you happen to
work for them and would be interested in
seeing that we'd love to work with you
on that yeah but our implementation is
very portable so generally speaking you
know most the cloud providers have some
sort of Linux II kind of option and that
tends to work fine for us okay question
in the back there maybe yeah so if you
want to run these algorithms on the
cloud and it's typically probably a
longer running algorithms the cloud some
machines don't work as intended what do
you do about fail at all odds yeah so I
would say that we share the HP HPC has
traditionally have this theme of like
just run fast and if it fails kind of
run again or Check Point restart and we
haven't done anything in chapel's so far
any better than that so if the machine
fails we don't sort of do anything
magical or automatic there and that's
another area where we'd like to do
additional research potentially in a
collaborative manner so again that's a
topic of interest people in the room
we'd be very interested talking about
that yeah cool ok let's think again
[Applause]
okay so up next we have John Leo is
gonna tell us about you know type theory
and music which is not something you
hear combined every day there's
ornaments and music if I know John
there's gonna be types in there
okay sure alright Johnny alright so I
would like to start out with some a
little bit of background in motivation
and then I'll talk a little bit about a
kind of fun project I've been working on
this is available online but it's still
very preliminary so it will probably
change quite drastically so I like to
start out with my favorite quote by Bob
Harper which is worth savoring for a
moment eventually all the arbitrary
programming languages are going to just
be swept away with the oceans and we'll
have the permanence of constructive
intuitionistic type theory is the master
theory of computation without doubt in
my mind no question so from my point of
view this is a personal statement
working in anything else is a waste of
time so I yeah I love this quote I agree
with it I've you know I'm really into
both math and computer science and and
I'd love to see this convergence so so
this is a good question I asked you know
what would programming look like in 50
years and and I I kind of agree with
with Bob's vision about this we already
have kind of things pointing the way
there's functional programming there's a
lot of work been done in algebra algebra
programming mostly based at Oxford
actually using math you know with with
in your programming and then now we that
was mostly done in the context of kind
of pure functional programming but now
we have dependent types where you can do
even even more math and then there's
even newer things coming out now there's
cubicle type theory and so forth and but
there's also question you know who does
the programming right because I mean
certainly from my experiences most
programmers hate math so they're really
willing to learn all this but you know I
don't know maybe 50 or some now that
computers will be programming themselves
but I think they'll be doing it written
in and programming and type theory
all right so given this is the goal how
do we actually get there
so we have we have some finally some
kind of industrial-strength functional
programming languages Haskell and oh
camel so we could try adding dependent
types to them and certainly that's being
done for Haskell and even now in Haskell
you can kind of fake dependent types
using a ton of extensions but it's very
ugly another way to do it is just take
some you know language that was designed
from the start for dependent types
something like Agni or interests and try
to make it practical to use and I think
it'll be interesting to see which one of
those two wins out meanwhile you know
how do we even program using a Penta
types this is really something that no
one no one's done yet I mean no one's
trying to write dependently type
programming is you know for industry or
whatever and you know I've done
functional programming in industry and
even then it's not exactly clear you
know what's the right way to write
functional programming so it's still
kind of even in is infancy and dependent
types is even you know yeah not even up
to that level and it's clear there's
still gonna be a lot of you know both
theoretical and practical advances
needed to get to this point so maybe
these are all interesting things to look
at what I wanted to kind of concentrate
here on is is you know let's actually
start trying to program using to pen a
types so so going back a little bit when
I was first learning Haskell in 2014 I
came across this wonderful book by Paul
Hudak and the system that he had written
called utopia which was a system to do
music and and I'm very interested in
music and I've done a little you know
composition and stuff like that but I'm
very lazy because you know I don't want
to have to spend a lot of time on it I
actually have some music software but
none of it's been quite what I wanted to
use but who the utopia was actually
close to what I wanted to do here's
something we could represent music you
know using a programming language you
could kind of do math e types of things
with it so it seemed it seemed very cool
to use so but but the Euterpe was kind
of based on old haskell and stuff like
that I thought well maybe I can make a
better more modern version so I started
working on something called music tools
it's just basically the idea is as a
small toolkit of you know very small
programs the the
have a very specific purpose you can
combine them together you know using
functional programming techniques or
whatever and with the idea to help help
you synthesize and analyze music and so
forth so I originally wrote it in in
Haskell but then I thought you know
going back to this thing well you know
if dependent types of the greatest thing
why don't why don't why am I not using
them so I tried converting it to AG des
and actually it was interesting because
I actually even found some some bugs in
the Haskell version when I made the
types more specific so it actually
already was paying off a little bit
I still do use Haskell you don't
actually you know get anything to you
know have i/o and so forth but it
actually worked out pretty well and I
think it's a good domain to actually
start with because you know dependent
type languages are not exactly
performant yet but here's something
where we don't need you know incredible
performance we can kind of do stuff in
batch mode and it's still reasonably
fast and it's it's you know it's a nice
domain right music is fairly
well-described and so forth but it's
still still fairly rich and and then the
exciting thing too is is you know I've
been doing some some research with with
Talia and Natan and dan and some of the
stuff that we are doing look like it
would apply to this as well so I thought
well here's a chance I can I can play
with this so I wasn't sure if I'd have
time to play in any music but I had some
requests so maybe I'll see if this works
so here's a little piece that I wrote a
very simple song I wrote back back in
the day and this this is actually sorry
I kind of reimplemented it in we'll see
if this works well maybe not all right
well sorry about that you might just try
to play it on your speakers oh yeah but
then I have to figure out how to change
the audio output so anyway well don't
worry about that but I could show it to
you a little bit what it looks like so
basically there's there's four there's
kind of four lines hear a melody
accompaniment bass and drums and the the
melody I essentially just wrote out for
an
but there's actually some structure to
it and you know I could take advantage
of that or maybe I mean what's maybe
interesting is how the program kind of
figure out the structure and recreate it
but as you can see for the accompaniment
has a little more structure so we're
actually able to use some some
functional program you think you see
maps and zips and stuff like that in
there and and the bass and the drums
even even more structure so you can make
them even more minimal in fact the very
first thing I did with utopia was tried
to write like minimal version of the the
Hanan exercises with them if you if you
know those piano exercises alright so
anyway so to you know to get this to
work and have a nice tool we need a good
representation of music you know how do
you represent music and and you know I
thought about it for awhile and I I
don't think there's a perfect
representation there's you know a lot of
good ways to do it they all have pluses
and minuses so right now I'm using
something that's pretty close to utopia
where you know you have pitches and
durations they kind of make notes out of
them and then music out of that you can
compose things in sequential
sequentially or in parallel but you know
Manou tiss there's some ambiguity here
you can kind of represent music and in
multiple ways that sound equivalent you
know there's equivalents kind of
structurally there's equivalent musical
equivalents and this is something that
your turkey has to deal with as well for
example you can have zero length rests
in there which actually is a common
thing you'll do if you're folding and
your zero length rigs as you as your
base case so here's you know just even a
more concrete example for pitch itself
we can represent us a sort of absolute
pitch which I have at the top but then
we could also represent it as a relative
pitch within an octave and then paired
with the octave right so now if we wrote
all these functions using one we want to
actually use them using the other one
you know what do you do you can convert
back and forth and so forth but the nice
thing is there's this you know some nice
research being done on this that we can
actually apply here so the homotopy type
theory gives you a way to you know first
define equivalence and then lift it up
to functions based on that equivalence
and and now since we're using dependent
types we can make advantage of take
advantage of this research and actually
do it so
so there's been some work on this
there's a paper equivalences for free
which might also appear in I CFP we'll
see done by some people at inria in Kok
and I've been kind of moving this over
to the AG de world and using it for that
but there's still some problems here
even though you do get a lot of
equivalences for free just the bass
equivalence --is themselves are are can
be rather painful to to define and you
know it seems like this could be
automated in some way and and I think
you know the were actually the work
Talia's doing now should be very very
helpful for this so even beyond
equivalences so my definition of music I
left out something that was in Hudak's
he had an extra little thing this modify
control and and so this actually has
some extra information and in fact you
can even put ornaments in your music but
I'm not sure I want to do it this way
yet I'm still thinking about it
but you know this is the way I think
Justin Stuart's talk today he was
talking about you know adding this
native thing to the other things and
then you know that's going to pervade
everything right so so here too we we
have this kind of core musical thing but
then we have this extra information we
want to add and how can we deal with
that and so here there's a another two
ornaments which which atalia nicely
already talked about in her talk which
is kind of you could think of as a
generalization of equivalences where now
you you have kind of more information on
one side than the other and again you
can kind of do this automatic lifting
and so forth with that so so this is
also something I'm adding to this here
the main challenge has been that all
this work although it's actually done in
Agda which is nice for me they did all
it with deep embeddings which made it
very nice you know for them to do
theoretical things with it but we need a
shallow embedding and agnus so I'm I'm
kind of using reflection mechanism and
Agda to try to convert between the deep
and the shallow embedding x' so anyway
so to conclude I think this has been a
great application area and I'm looking
forward to playing with it more I really
you know just like just like types
people don't want to you know put in the
effort to do math at first it's a lot of
work but but I think it pays off and
and then part of the goal of this
project is to figure out how to minimize
that work and and still get the rewards
of using the math any questions for John
so - starting oh good words in ER it's
just too early you're just too early
it's too early in a way but I think
already the equivalents of stuff is has
been really nice
so so III definitely it's very promising
how's that yeah so on the high side on
style transfers you know people do with
art also presumably music you like to
make up Bach hiccup to make a box style
so does that relate to this yeah I mean
this this isn't tend to be the kind of
foundation to do that stuff in so
there's actually even a lot of other
work there's a lot of stuff in Haskell
going on now there's something called
harm trace to things to do harmonic
analyses and they use the type system to
enforce harmonic rules and stuff like
that and this is all again this is
intended to be like a bass system at all
that can be built out of and I think I
can redo for example the harm trace
stuff using dependent types will be a
lot more elegant than what they're doing
out with a lot of Haskell extensions
again so you mentioned that you need a
shallow embedding is that for the MIDI
interface through high school no it's
just to get the ornament stuff to work
on real agda code so right now you'd
need to in the deep embedding you'd need
to you know define all your types and as
this embedded thing instead of using
like real you know natural numbers or
whatever even so so they define these
things as you know fix points of
functors and they're deep embedding and
things like that so it's a matter of
translating between these two worlds
okay any more questions for John all
right so let's take John again
[Applause]